excellente nouvelle regardez ce que j'ai
reçu aujourd'hui est en train de casser
tout matin ce pack est là ce pack est là
et je viens de pâques est alors le truc
qui est cool c'est que j'attendais
depuis un bon moment et je suis très
content de pouvoir faire avec vous c'est
l'arrivée des galaxy note 10 j'ai pris
le note 10 voulu et cool parce que alors
je fasse si vous avez suivi
il ya quelques jours je vous ai parlé du
9-10 plus et du 9 10 dans une prise en
main simple chez samsung a parlé je vais
y arriver il est dans cette boîte
on va se faire un déballage de rapides
dans l'idée ce n'est pas de faire le
test aujourd'hui parce que j'ai pas le
temps je les ai donc le ton de voix là
mais je voulais vraiment partager ça
avec vous c'était l'ouverture de la
boîte c'était voir comment cet effet et
je pense que sa lettre
j'avais bien up
regardez-moi ça ce précieux sésame
c'est magnifique on ouvre on regarde ce
qu'il ya à l'intérieur comment c'est
fait on découvre ça ensemble
et puis après on se dit à demain à jouer
les gros bisou pour commencer et je
ferai des gros billets se vendent pas
tiens donc
[Musique]
regardez ça commence regardez-moi ça
comme ça sympa suite à un malaise j'aime
bien la garnotte est toujours jolie une
année on avait tous deux jeunes qu'on
retrouve pas cette année mais bon ma foi
c'est élégant c'est sympa l'oise et le
premier paquet et là j'ai deuxième
paquet deuxième paquet à regardez-moi ça
des protections parce que ce smartphone
et coûte quand même un peu cher c'est du
premium forcément il faut des
protections protection rhinochill
solliciteurs ya pas que ça il ya
d'autres choses de chérine aussi je vous
en parle lors du test penser à le
protéger ses importants ailleurs si vous
intéresse vous avez un lien dans la
description pour les coques rhino chine
et la même chose pour le smartphone
mouvement préférait les feuillages
cinéma ouvre à de jeunes gens tout va
bien jolies bottes
moi j'aime bien je trouve que une fois
de plus sauvé le samsung vont vous avez
la gamme à vous vous avez des boîtes
plutôt blanche et dès que vous arrivez
dans le premium vous allez dans son côté
un peu plus classieuses qui me paraît
aussi normal parce que forcément le
produit plus cher
il avoue laver et en plus ce qui est
génial c'est ce que j'aime beaucoup en
tout cas d'un design laqué fait
effectivement de la par samsung c'est
vous retrouvez ce style et la wii avec
les reflets c'est être mieux ce style et
qui dessine tout de suite laden du
produit c'est beau c'est l'ego et je
sais pas s'ils vont marquer ce qui est
très intéressant tire très bien c'est
que sur la boîte à aucun moment de ce
côté là n'a parlé samsung s'est montré à
quel point en tout cas il ya une force
de frappe au niveau de ce stylet qui
permet d'identifier tout de suite le
produire bien évidemment notre disent
plus que vous retrouvez en bar les
voiliers samsung se dit on n'a pas
besoin de marquer samsung ca c et si
vous leur premier critère 500 que vous
l'avez ici écrit noir sur noir enfin
coûte à peu brillant pour retrouver
c'est assez rigolo sur les deux fuyards
rien là y'a rien là y'a numéro de série
et aux deux jours trop effectivement les
informations samsung galaxy note 10 plus
c'est la version 256 go de stockage
bon vous avez la fiche technique ça on
l'a déjà vu ensemble donc on passe
maintenant passe à l'ouverture
je sais pas si vous remarquez dans le
studio il ya un peu moins de bazar il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été enlevés
tout simplement parce que je suis en
train de préparer d'installer le tout
nouveau studio donc la voyez j'ai fait
un peu places vides les choses s'en vont
les choses changent les choses évoluent
c'est sympa on s'ennuie c'est que nous
allons regarder comment nous ça il faut
ouvrir cette petite partie l'opération
dr deseur on ouvre les patients on va le
disséquer
très soul eu j'aurais dû prendre un
discours et je pense que ce serait
vachement mieux g ok un petit effort
madame poussé d'accouchement ça fait
toujours une douleur
malheureusement on y est presque on y
est presque un dernier effort
il arrive c'est un garçon formidable
alors normalement vous le trouvez pas
comme ça comment louper un peu son vin
doux que c'est en ne votant pas j'en ai
en place un nom de dj trop secouer j'ai
trop secouer voilà donc je pensais être
probablement comme ça comme ça ça
c'était comment ça je ne sais pas bon
alors on passe un peu normalement vous
arrivez tac vous avez le sonar 20 dès
que vous ouvrez qui se présente comme ça
ça c'est plutôt cool
si vous prenez un peu le côté sans souci
vous connaissez déjà à l'intérieur vous
allez retrouver ici
hop tout déjà découvrir votre tiroir de
karting passer plus de trains et à
l'intérieur quand vous avez de la
documentation
on peut l'intérêt du truc alors bon en
règle générale je sais pas vous dîtes le
manque au mental et moi je lis pas j'ai
un peu l'habitude même avant d'avoir
l'habitude je ne lisais pas en chef vous
avez dit prise en main rapide carte de
garantie
voilà pour débloquer tout va bien tout
est simple tout est mignon tout est
sympathique
donc vous avez tout les petits papiers
comment transférer le contenu dans votre
nouveau téléphone d'accepter ça peut
être vachement intéressant smart switch
l'application qui est vraiment simple
sympa facile à utiliser
ça c'est plutôt cool si vous souhaitiez
effectivement je dirais d'un d'un
smartphone qui autre qu'un samsung vous
n'avez pas de sauvegarde ans le club de
saintes sont guéris ça peut être
intéressant à voir le smartphone en
lui-même avec la partie toujours un
petit peu très imple euros le nom de
plus près par demos truc c'est
magnifique
regardez-moi ça moi j'adore franchement
je le dis je suis très très très fan de
dos on le voit beaucoup dans les médias
vous allez vraiment ce côté avec ce ce
côté arc-en-ciel argentée qui est
vraiment super beau et normalement
d'avoir une protection d'écran sur
l'avant si je ne me trompe pas voilà
juste alors à la différence du galaxy
folle celle ci vous pouvez l'enlever
sans être rationnel on parle du
smartphone dans quelques jours donc pour
l'instant c'est pas l'objet d'une colle
la déduction pour aujourd'hui on en
parle dans quelques jours laissez moi le
temps de bien prendre en main je l' ai
pris en main le fois pendant une heure à
deux heures chez samsung c'est vraiment
la découverte
maintenant je vais aller beaucoup plus
haut niveau des tests et je pense que la
semaine prochaine je serai en mesure de
dire des choses là dessus donc rester
connecté abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas ça c'est vraiment cool
à l'intérieur de la balle donc
normalement ça s'est pas mis en bazar
comme ça mais vous connaissez la
délicatesse légendaire jeu la petite et
trop secouer qu'est-ce qu'on a bien par
la manque aucun là vous avez de
l'adaptateur usb vers usb c'est pour
pouvoir briguer pas mal de petites
choses directement dans votre smartphone
donc ça ça peut vraiment avoir un
intérêt vous brancher directement de
l'usb c'est génial après y avoir plein
de vie plein d' usage on en repart un
peu plus tard
ça c'est pour changer je pense la mine
de votre stylet vous l'avez là vous avez
de quoi la trappe et la sortie a donc ça
c'est vraiment cool
ensuite vous l'avez si votre bloc de
charges dont ça s'est un petit peu
classique qu'il est ici en usb c'est ok
on a vous le voyez là des écouteurs à kg
savez que c'est obligatoire en avant des
écouteurs filaires dans un smartphone la
france qu'on trouve pas partout donc là
vous avez votre câble j'imagine usb
j'aime bien vraiment le côté packaging
s'est toujours bien ya un côté
effeuillage on prend le temps réel des
comme ça sous c'est très bien fait parce
qu'on peut l'ouvrir complètement sans
tout déchirer je ne suis pas sûr je le
fais glisser
j'ai eu six usb usb c'est donc ça ça ne
marche et là je vais avoir mes écouteurs
à kg de la même manière
normalement je dois voir des tees en
bouche on attend de savoir comment
surtout ce truc là aussi voilà j'adore
j'aime bien en plus j'aime bien le
travail qui est fait par un casier au
niveau de langue et donc c'est plutôt de
bien voir donc j'ai ça le cordon qui a
un côté va sûrement rhénium regardez là
ça c'est cool et à côté de ça on est sur
du premium avec ce smartphone est donc
c'est normal vous avez des petits en
bout pour s'installer aux oreilles de
tout le monde donc ça si c'est cool
vachement bien en voilà belle finition
beau produit bien fait bien packagée une
fois de plus un géant dans la lignée de
ce que sait faire le samsung très
clairement sur sur des produits très
haut de gamme comme la gamme note ça
c'est vachement bien bon a pris à
l'intérieur on a fait le tour
néanmoins voyez même là là c'est pas un
truc un peu plastique vulgaire on a
l'impression que c'est un espèce de
bulle j'en sais rien je paie la bêtise
espèce de composites un peu froid j'en
sais rien c'est que ça fait pas oui on
n'est pas son truc un petit peu un petit
peu toc l'impression qu'à côté un peu
éco responsable au niveau des matériaux
qui était choisi ce sera tout ça bien
évidemment validé mais je trouve sa
couleur vous avez si l'algérie je
connais
mettez que vous y connaissez unix
packages on a une norme fsc
si vous vous y connaissez pouvait
marquer tous ces commentaires c'est
toujours intéressant de voir un petit
peu d'avoir l'expertisé votre expertise
là dessus donc moi je trouve ça cool une
fois de plus très beau produit ça c'est
une évidence et déjà testé il est
vachement fin j'ai déjà pris à montreuil
super bien excellent production sera
absolument pas déçu et une fois de plus
vous l'aurait dit bien pensé à le
protéger on en a on va mettre laquelle
la halle et moi c'est cet espace avec le
carbone toujours de cheminots chine on
prend autant le choix et la bim bam boum
la magie opère et normalement c'est
vachement cool
voyez salle élargit un peu plus par
contre smartphones vu le prix de la bête
c'est quand même dommage de faire tomber
d'échappée donc je vous conseille une
fois de plus de le protéger et je vous
dis vous avez un tarif avec une remise
chez rhinochill qui mon partenaire pour
les coqs
donc si ça vous botte de l'histoire qui
venait voilà tout ça pour ce monsieur
bré castot voilà pour ce smartphone
qu'on va tester d'ici quelques jours
voilà pour cette boîte qui écoule
samsung égal à lui-même qui va toujours
est ce que ce serait un petit peu floue
la taxe samsung
il fait une chaleur vous avez pas assez
on est sur la fin de l'été c'est cool
mais fut une chaleur atocas éthique
aussi l'épanouissement de produits je
tiens aussi à les voir si j'aurais vous
samsung égal à lui-même au niveau de sa
qualité dans le très haut de gamme dans
le premium avec des packagings toujours
très soignée très distingué une
expérience au niveau du déshabillage du
produit on est vraiment un côté un peu
essayé à ce jour c'est jacques houssin
peut censurer quand on va ouvrir un
smartphone ne sais pas vous quand vous
achetez vos smartphones est ce que pour
vous il ya un côté un petit peu aller on
ouvre avec sensuel c'est un peu poussé
mais j'aime bien voyons on touche des
matériaux la des matériaux qui sont
quand même assez noble on a un vrai
travail vrai choix qui est fait
justement au niveau des matériaux
choisis de l'expérience utilisateur au
moment où on va l'ouvrir vous retrouver
dans le très haut de gamme vous le
retrouvez bien évidemment ce soupçon
mais c'est aussi un pelage aux dépenses
à peu près aussi chez apple dans l'oeuf
est allé on tire un truc tout souffre
comme par magie c'est vachement mer donc
je trouve ça intéressant beau chouette
une fois de plus très beau travail le
smartphone on en parle d'ici quelques
jours a volé vous ce n'est pas déjà
craqué là vous me dire ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que vous l'avez commandé un des
deux notes 10 note 10 plus si oui lequel
vers lequel votre coeur balance tout
d'un côté puis de l'autre
dites moi ce que vous avancez on parle
d'une
plus aujourd'hui on parlera probablement
d'une dispute un d'ailleurs à vous de me
dire si vous voulez qu'on parle aussi
d'une autre liste si vous voyez qui 1
si vous voulez être qu'on les compare
qu'on regarde lequel et voilà pour l ie
vous correspond vous marquez tout
semblant comme attaquant donne rendez
vous extrêmement rapidement le temps de
faire un bisou monde et je vous dis bien
écouter probablement à demain si ce
n'est pas après demain voilà gros bécaud
ou prenez soin de vos stops